we often think of a Bernoulli process as
a stream of arriving traffic what
happens if we merge two streams for
example consider a server that receives
traffic from two independent sources how
do we describe the total traffic that
arrives to this server here's a precise
model we have two streams that
correspond to Bernoulli processes with
some parameters each P and Q
respectively
and each one of these processes receives
arrivals at certain times that we
indicate by crosses and similarly for
the second process we assume that these
two processes are independent and what
we mean by this is that any collection
of random variables associated with the
first process will be independent from
any collection of random variables
associated with the second process we
now merge the two processes as follows
whenever there is an arrival in any of
the original processes we record an
arrival in the merged process as in this
picture notice that we do not make a
distinction between those slots at which
there was an arrival in only one of the
original process versus those slots in
which there was an arrival in both of
the original processes in both cases we
just say that there was an arrival in
the merged process and so collisions
arrivals in both of the original
processes are counted as only one
arrival in the merged process now what
can we say about the merged process we
will argue that it is a Bernoulli
process with a certain parameter that we
will compute to check the Bernoulli
property for the merged process the
first thing we need to ensure is the
independence assumption independence
across slots let us look at two typical
slots and to do this it helps to define
some notation that XT and YT
the original processes and let ZT be the
merged process the random variable Z T
is determined in some way by the random
variables XT and YT if I told you if
there was an arrival in the first and
the second process you can tell whether
there was an arrival in the merged
process and similarly the random
variable Z T plus one is determined in
some way from XT plus one and YT plus
one what this is saying is that whether
we have an arrival at this slot is
determined by what happens in these two
slots and whether we have an arrival in
this slot is determined by whatever
happens in these two slots now we have
assumed that the two processes are
independent so these two random
variables are independent from those two
random variables and furthermore across
time this random variable will be
independent from that random variable
and this random variable will be
independent from that random variable so
these four random variables are
independent of each other because of
this we have ZT a function of two random
variables that are independent from the
two random variables that determine ZT
plus one and for this reason ZT and ZT
plus one will be independent
this proves a pairwise independence
property for the merged process but we
can extend this argument to argue that
the collection of random variables Z 1
up to ZT is a collection of independent
random variables so we have the
independence property now let us
calculate the probability of an arrival
during a typical slot during a typical
time slot there are four possibilities
for what may occur and these
possibilities have to do with whether in
the X process we have an arrival or not
and in the
I process whether we have an arrival or
not the probability that we have an
arrival in both processes because of
Independence is the product of the
probability that we have an arrival in
the first process with the probability
that we have an arrival in the second
process similarly there is a probability
P of an arrival in the first process and
no arrival in the second there is a
probability 1 minus P of no arrival in
the first process and an arrival in the
second process and finally there is
probability 1 minus P times one minus Q
of no arrival in either of the two
processes the probability that we have
an arrival in the merged process is the
probability of this green event these
are the cases in which an arrival gets
recorded in the merged process so the
probability of an arrival in the merged
process is the sum of those three
probabilities or another way to
calculate it is 1 minus this probability
here namely 1 minus 1 minus P times 1
minus Q and after you expand this
product and do some cancellations you
end up with this expression which is the
probability of an arrival during a slot
in the merged process of course this
probability is constant across time and
this together with the independence
property establishes that the merged
process is actually a Bernoulli process
now let us end by answering one more
question if I told you that at a certain
time slot there was at least one arrival
in the two processes which means that
there was an arrival in the merged
process what is the probability that
there was an arrival in the first
process now the event that there was an
arrival in the first process is this
event here so we're trying to calculate
the conditional probability of the blue
event given that the green event has
occurred we use the definition of
conditional probabilities the
conditional probability is
equal to the probability that both
events happen which in this case is the
intersection of the blue and the green
event which coincides with the blue
event and the probability of the blue
event is the sum of these two numbers is
equal to P and then we divide by the
probability of the conditioning event
this is the probability of an arrival
but this is what we have just calculated
which is P plus Q minus P times Q